[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
the big headline from the long weekend
Donald Trump wants to end Dhaka what is
Dhaka and what would ending it do that's
a good place to start let's dig into it
Dhaka stands for deferred action for
childhood arrivals childhood arrivals
means people who were children when
their parents came to the United States
with them illegally the deferred action
being referred to is as you might
imagine deportation of those kids and
President Barack Obama remember him he
passed a program which shielded children
from deportation and it makes perfect
sense if you think about it if you're a
kid and you come to the US illegally
because your parents brought you you
grow up here you were not old enough to
decide for yourself what to do you were
not old enough to consider the legality
of what it was your parents were doing
you should not be punished and we should
not deport you particularly because the
average age of entry was six six years
old and you basically have a life in the
United States I moved to the United
States legally of course when I was five
and a half years old nearly six years
old and the idea of taking me at 26 for
example as are some of the dreamers the
so-called dreamers in this as referred
to under this program they take a 26
year old and say hey your parents came
here illegally so you're going back to
your home country which for many of
those individuals particularly if they
haven't been back it's not really their
home country anymore and we've learned
that Donald Trump is going to be ending
that program maybe after giving Congress
six months to propose a replacement Jeff
Sessions officially making the
announcement today yet another sign of
just Donald Trump's it's sort of just
like a scaredy cat right I mean why
can't he come out and make this
announcement himself sending Jeff
Sessions out there and the idea is if
Congress can propose a replacement that
actually goes through Congress not
something that President Obama just put
in place that will keep these dreamers
in the US without being deported then
Trump is I guess willing to consider
that but even among Republicans this
isn't a unanimously popular idea Paul
Ryan and a growing list of Republicans
and of course all Democrats they
some form of this program to stay in
place and what they're using pad is
they're saying it was not done in a
constitutionally correct way you need to
go through Congress to do it and Jeff
Sessions kind of almost threw up a
little bit in my mouth when I heard him
say it he said that this was actually
the repeal the the rescinding of daca
daca was an act of compassion and I
don't know how you could think that
that's some serious mental gymnastics
there and you know daca does affect
800,000 people and within that group of
young adults obviously you're gonna have
good and bad you're gonna have
successful and not successful but some
of those people you know are in elite
universities some serve in the military
I'm saying as corporations in the whole
country so even from an economic
standpoint how can you rationalize this
I think it's just a clear move to the
base well like much of what Trump is
proposing and we'll talk about the trade
with China stuff later
much of what Trump is proposing would
have economically disastrous
consequences which of course Trump has
not the brain power to understand a key
sort of practical question with this
repeal of daca is during this six-month
trial period of sorts until and we see
if we will get a replacement proposal
from Congress would people who receive
deferrals already do to daca be allowed
to renew that status if it comes up for
renewal during that six-month period
unclear maybe we will know some of these
elements by tomorrow it's also important
to realize that according to a report
from 538 regardless of what ultimately
happens with this six-month period or a
replacement or whatever
Trump's threats alone so far when it
comes to undocumented immigration are
already having an impact an online
survey was done if daca recipients and
it found that about one out of five 20%
of respondents who were eligible already
to renew their status had not done so
many because they believe that if they
do that that information that they
submit will be used by the government to
identify and maybe find them for law
enforcement purposes and for other
reasons so this is already having an
impact no matter what ultimately happens
and it really shouldn't be too much of a
surprise to us because on the campaign
trail Trump said that you would go after
birthright citizenship with all anchor
babies sure and so if he's willing to
target you know people not only who have
control over their situation but where
they're born into children babies I mean
you can see how this would extend to
daka's yeah if he's willing to go after
people born in the u.s. he's willing to
go after five-year-olds who came to the
US illegally because their parents
brought them no doubt about it
daka's good policy but with Trump
there's always also a double standard in
the background or in the foreground as
it sometimes is I want to remind you
that Melania Trump first lady of the
United States Donald Trump's wife came
to the US and worked illegally she
worked in the US before she had legal
authorization to do so she has not been
punished the modeling companies that
hired her haven't been punished period
more than a year ago in August of 2016
Donald Trump said at a rally in North
Carolina Melania Trump will be holding a
press conference within a few weeks to
explain and address that issue that
never happened
being married to Trump that seems to be
the real job that Americans aren't
willing to do at this point and by the
way I was as I was reading all about the
daca stuff over the weekend Pat why does
the alt-right and why do white
nationalists even like Trump he's
married to an immigrant who was working
in the US illegally his daughter and
son-in-law are Jewish and he's indebted
to Russia look what what is appealing to
a white nationalist about it I think it
goes back to what Frank mink said on the
program last week which is when Trump
announced that he was running for
president he had this whole thing about
you know the Mexicans are coming here
illegally and you know some I assume are
good people when really you're supposed
to be flipping that whole script around
yeah that from the get-go I think
grabbed their attention yeah I guess
they haven't left them since Slovenian
models aren't exactly the stereotype of
the people Trump has painted as the
really bad ones that we don't want in
the country okay three common issues
that the president talks about trade
North Korea and China those three issues
are being combined into one Donald
Trump's new idea is to stop all trade
with any country that does business with
North Korea okay Donald Trump took to
Twitter he tweeted the United States is
considering in addition to other options
stopping all trade with any country
doing business with North Korea
riah of course one of the countries that
does business with North Korea is China
now I want to be clear I'm not some
defender of Chinese government
depression or the lack of free speech or
or anything else that exists there right
I'm not defending any of it but I still
want to point out why this is an
absolutely an utterly crazy idea and I
want to remind you before we even do
that Donald Trump does a lot of business
with China much of his men's clothing
line is manufactured in China a few
months ago China provisionally granted
Donald Trump's businesses 38 different
trademarks Trump is doing huge business
in China but apparently China would be
punished for doing business with North
Korea okay how many of us read about
Donald Trump's threat to North Korea on
a computer or mobile device that was
assembled partially or wholly in China
China runs many aspects of our lives
period I'm not defending it I'm not
saying it's good you can move
manufacturing elsewhere it'll take a
long time and it might cost more but if
you end trade with China because they do
business with North Korea you destroy
the American economy in a number of ways
including that immediately tons of goods
sold in the u.s. become way more
expensive that is really bad for the
lower and middle class you [ __ ] huge
American companies now some people will
like that but you'll do it in a way that
will exert downward economic pressure
and it would be hugely damaging to the
people that supposedly Donald Trump was
running for the little guy the average
person of course we never bought it but
that's who it would hurt do you think
for a second Pat that Donald Trump
understands the potential impact of no
longer trading with China trade has been
one of those issues where Donald Trump
can speak passionately because I think
you know relative to the other issues
that he knows about he's able to use a
little bit more knowledge on it I agree
and he's also not really thinking ahead
in terms of wet weather like what would
you really be punishing China who who
exactly would be punished American
buyers of Chinese goods would still be
able to buy them indirectly at a small
price increase maybe you buy them from
someone that does business with
China but doesn't do business with North
Korea and of course the alternative
would be that China can stop trading
with North Korea but trade indirectly
with them through another country and
that's sort of how the slave trade
actually worked law a law would be
passed against importing slaves from a
particular country so then that source
country would send the slaves to a
different country and then you import
them from there you're just putting in a
middleman and adding to the cost of all
of these transactions which it's insane
to think of buying humans as an economic
transaction but that is what it once was
in Trump scenario you're setting up
exactly that same situation and this is
also more broadly nonsense because it's
just not a credible threat from Trump
it's such an obviously empty threat that
it doesn't communicate strength China
knows it isn't credible North Korea
knows this is not a credible threat so
it doesn't even benefit the United
States for Trump to make the threat
there's also this five year old trade
deal with South Korea's a free trade
deal that he's threatening now because
he's accusing the South Koreans of
practicing appeasement when it comes to
North Korea keep in mind these are the
people that are most vulnerable to any
sort of missile attack Ernie and
supposedly our allies as well right so
it doesn't make any sense and oh by the
way North Korea also imports from Mexico
a huge huge huge trading partner for the
United States also would be disastrous
to cut that off so everybody wants this
resolved some people want it resolved in
a tweet and it's not going to be ending
trade with China and Mexico is so absurd
that it is not even remotely credible as
something that Donald Trump would do and
the likely reality is there's not going
to be a simple solution in North Korea
that doesn't involve some combination of
significant economic conflict and/or
military involvement not that I'm
recommending it but the the idea that
things are going to drastically change
in North Korea without some combination
of those two things doesn't seem
particularly likely to me and I've been
reading more and more individuals who
are saying hey you know what we should
take a different approach to North Korea
we should say hey North Korea you know
what you're a country like other
countries you can research nuclear
technology but you've got to play by the
rules you have to allow inspectors and
we will remove
a lot of the threats that you are on the
receiving end of and allow you to do the
research but you've got to play by the
rules and it's a controversial idea but
it's when I'm reading more and more
about and maybe we'll talk about it a
little bit later in week I'm on Twitter
at D Pakman the program is on twitter at
david pakman show we'll take a break and
be back after this the david pakman show
at david pakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com today's new member of the
days till smiley bill thank you so much
for being a david pakman show member you
can join bill at david pakman.com slash
membership you can also get a $1 trial
membership this is a cool thing we
started this last week you go to david
pakman.com slash dollar for $1 you can
get a trial membership for a week if you
don't like membership you don't have to
continue if you do like it I hope that
you will stay and become a full member
using any one of the various coupon
codes that are available you can pay
full price but david pakman.com slash
dollar gets you a trial full membership
for a week you can also make a pledge at
patreon.com slash david pakman show and
lastly if you shop on amazon go to david
pakman.com slash amazon before shopping
and everything you buy will send us a
little kickback very quick reminder 24
hours left to get your submissions in
for the free membership contest Patrick
Ferreira came to me with a proposal for
a membership giveaway the proposal is
you submit some kind of visual art
related to the david pakman show to
instagram with the hashtag david pakman
show seventeen okay let's put up the
hashtag just to make sure everybody
knows exactly what it is it can be
anything related to the show a comic a
caricature of producer Pat an
interpretive an interpretive poem
related to Pat's Keurig usage whatever
right but the idea is it's art of some
kind and you tagged it on instagram with
david pakman show 17:5 people will be
selected tomorrow to receive a free
one-year membership you can also follow
me and tag me there i'm on instagram at
david pakman let's talk about Vice
President Mike Pence major question in
the context of the Trump Russia
investigation what did Mike Pence know
when did he know it if Trump goes down
should pence go down with him and I will
mind you that former FBI director james
comey this is a key fact for what I'm
about to tell you James Comey was fired
on May 9th seems like a it's stunning
that it's been made June July August
it's been almost four months just
happens that so much has happened since
then but May ninth is the day that James
Comey was fired as FBI director there is
a new blockbuster story from the New
York Times which puts Mike Pence
squarely in the Oval Office on May 8th
the day before James Comey was fired
participating in a review of a letter
that Donald Trump and advisor Steven
Miller put together explaining why James
Comey was about to be fired
Donald Trump said on 8th I'm firing
Comey here's a letter I drafted about
why now why is Mike Pence's presence at
that meeting so relevant Mike Pence
previously said very clearly very
unequivocally with absolutely no doubt
that when Comey was fired it was because
of the recommendation that Donald Trump
received from Deputy Attorney General
Rod Rosenstein okay here is a quote from
Mike Pence two reporters on May 10th the
day after the firing let me be very
clear that the president's decision to
accept the recommendation of the Deputy
Attorney General and the Attorney
General to remove director Comey as the
head of the FBI was based solely and
exclusively on his commitment to the
best interest of the American people and
to ensuring that the FBI has the trust
and confidence of the people in this
nation we of course eventually learned
the real reasons for the firing Trump
wanted to do it to deflate the Russia
investigation but now knowing that Mike
Pence was in the Oval Office on may 8th
when Donald Trump came to them and said
hey I'm firing Comey here's the letter
the letter explains the reasons this
means that on May 10th when Mike Pence
claimed Trump fired Comey on the
recommendation of the deputy AG pence
knew that it was a lie before we knew
this there was deniability right maybe
on May 10th Mike Pence believed
that the firing on the day before was
because of rod Rosen Stein's
recommendation we now know pence was in
the Oval Office and he read Trump's
letter on May 8th so he knew that he was
lying with his explanation on May 10th
this is of course not Mike Pence's only
lie he claimed in a TV interview that he
didn't know about Michael Flynn's
foreign work several people have since
come forward and said oh no Mike Pence
knew all about it but of course we can't
really know all of the things that Mike
Pence knew and when he knew them and
when he lied because for a while he was
using a private email account with
America Online I mean it is one of the
few connections that we have between
Mike Pence and the Russia scandal and
even even so I mean the connection has
to do with maybe like obstruction of
justice or the cover-up not with the
initial crime and of course pence joined
the Trump campaign so late in the game
as well do you think there would be
enough to really implicate him in all of
this I don't know I generally don't know
it and my concern is more that if if
Trump ultimately Falls and pence becomes
the president it's actually not that
great for anybody particularly the 300
plus million people who live in the
United States and many people around the
world so I think it's important to
anytime we have information about Mike
Pence's potential involvement this puts
him squarely in the middle of the insane
firing of James Comey motivated by the
Russia investigation so at least what we
know now is Pence's hands aren't clean
whether this will be enough to legally
implicate him at some future point I
have no idea it seems a little bit
surprising cuz pence doesn't seem like
someone who would lie oh I got that
impression religious conservative
question listen Indiana is not sending
us their best some people from Indiana I
know I'm sure are good people I've met
them but Indiana is just not sending us
our best folks that I can assure you
okay Paul Manafort remember that trump
tower meeting with Donald Trump jr. and
Paul Manafort and Jared Kushner and the
Russian lawyer Natalia vessel and it's
kaya and a Russian translator and I
don't even know who else was in there at
this point we now have learned about the
notes that Paul Manafort Trump's former
campaign chairman the notes that
Manafort took during that meeting and in
those notes there were references to
political contributions near a reference
to the Republican National Committee
mana forts notes were typed on a
smartphone and they were described by a
source that was briefed on the matter as
cryptic they've since been turned over
to the House and Senate intelligence
committees as well as to special counsel
robert muller for his investigation and
again the notes taken at that meeting
with the russian lawyer in Trump Tower
by Paul Manafort
referenced political contributions and
the Republican National Committee why is
this relevant it's relevant for many
reasons number one we were told that at
that meeting the only thing discussed
was Russian adoptions so if only Russian
adoptions were discussed why would Paul
Manafort have taken notes that reference
political contributions and the
Republican National Committee secondly
why would Paul Manafort have notes at
all if this meeting was one in which
absolutely nothing of note took place as
Donald Trump jr. has insisted time and
time again here are the two different
things that Donald Trump jr. said about
Paul Mann affords presence during that
bizarre interview with sean hannity
after that story broke here is part one
you know i think it became pretty
apparent to you know Jared and Paul who
I think Jared left after a few minutes
Paul got is his phone yeah we were all
begin Donald Trump jr. talking about
Paul mana for its involvement in that
meeting and Jared left after five or ten
yes like she said and Paul Manafort was
on his on his own the whole time pretty
much pretty much listen like I said he
was noting a pretty apparent that this
was not what we were in there talking
about so we mean I don't even know where
to start with this right there's so many
questions number one again political
contributions in RNC in a meeting with a
foreign a someone involved with a
foreign country it is illegal for
foreigners to donate to American
elections that's not really the news
here okay
the news is mana for took notes if this
was a non meeting if there was nothing
here if mana fort wasn't paying
attention why are there notes about the
RNC and political contributions and
Donald Trump jr. Pat claimed that the
meeting was insignificant citing manna
fort was just on the phone the entire
time it appears mana fort was on the
phone the entire time
I'm taking relatively detailed notes
about what was going on at that meeting
certainly Donald Trump jr. said that
Paul Manafort was on his phone the whole
time in a effort to try to make him look
disconnected or disinterested in what
was going on in the meeting but in
reality he could just be trying to
deceive that fox news audience because I
got the impression that Paul Manafort
was you know playing Angry Birds or
words with friends the whole time but
maybe he was just taking detailed notes
of the entire encounter you know what's
interesting that what Donald Trump jr.
said to Hannity it appears as though at
least with regard to Paul Manafort it
was sort of the letter of it was true
manna fort was on his phone the entire
time of course that wasn't a sign that
he wasn't paying attention it was a sign
that it was significant enough for him
to take notes he also mentioned Jared
left after just a few minutes
referencing Jared Kushner it's also
possible that that's true but not that
Jared Kushner left because the meeting
was insignificant rather he left because
he thought I don't want to be implicated
in what's going on here or I want to go
and tell Donald Trump senior immediately
about what it is that's going on we're
very quickly learning and in reviewing
by the way I watch that entire Donald
Trump jr. Sean Hannity interview again
yesterday preparing for the segment he
had a list of his own notes in front of
him and very often when Hannity was
asking him a question he would be
looking down at his notes we have to
assume that he was very specifically
prepared for that interview and the
words were chosen very carefully Paul
Manafort was on his phone the entire
time Jared Kushner left after just a few
minutes meant to give an impression of
insignificance when in reality those
actions by the two of them might have
been more reflective of the seriousness
of the meeting maybe we will find out
one day I really think that if there
were eight plus people in that meeting
you can find someone who can corroborate
a story that damages Paul Manafort
I mean many of those people in that
meeting were Russian so that could be
hard to find but if anyone's going to do
it it's gonna be Robert Muller yes and
we are still of course waiting to see
how Robert Muller is handling each
additional piece of information that
surfaces with regard to those meetings
and the investigation and everything
else that we've been talking about
discuss this with us on our reddit
discussion forum at david pakman.com
slash our EDD
next the myth of the violent left the
david pakman show at david pakman.com
[Music]
welcome back to the David Pakman show
if conservative news were your only
source for information you might be
thinking that conservatives and America
as a whole are under siege by gangs of
deranged violent bloodthirsty left
wingers teeming with hatred hell-bent on
destruction and being cheered on by the
Democratic Party and the liberal media
the Kathy Griffin beheading incident and
tufa protests the rendition of caesar
with a trump character and much more
seriously the recent shooting of
Republican Congressman Steve Scalise at
a Republican baseball team practice are
all being held up as evidenced by
right-wing pundits of violence hatred
and extremism being rampant on the left
and that liberal ideology poses a grave
danger to the country let's be clear the
threat of violence from people on the
Left should be of concern and monitored
closely particularly after the shooting
of Steve Scalise but there's been a
torrent of hysterical coverage night
after night from Fox News and other
right-wing outlets that is vastly
overblown sensationalized toxic and
horribly hypocritical and it ignores the
disproportionately high amount of
right-wing violence that we've seen for
many years and unfortunately it's been
pervading the narrative among the right
to give you a sense of just how out of
hand this narrative has gotten in
right-wing media listen to this foul
language directed right at our president
they hate him and now top Republican
Steve Scalise is in the hospital his
condition downgraded to critical a Trump
hater a leftist did this were it not for
the brave
of police officers it would have been a
massacre of Republicans there is a link
between the climate of violence and the
violent attack on Republicans it is a
link the left should acknowledge that
they will not instead Democrats are
pushing impeachment and the media has
returned to pejorative leaks which imply
the present obstructed justice barely
hours after a political shooting the
left and the media get right back on
track with partisan attacks and not a
word of remorse for the climate of
violence they did so much to create look
the tumultuous polarized political
climate we live in today is a problem
violent rhetoric and political hatred on
both sides are disturbing and we should
have conversations about how to simmer
it down but this sort of ludicrous
hypocritical coverage from Fox and other
right-wing media only serves to further
exacerbate the root cause of this kind
of violence and hatred the problem they
claim to be trying to solve for
conservative pundits to sit around and
cherry-pick violent rhetoric or actions
from a few people who are broadly
speaking ostensibly on the left while
pretending that violent rhetoric is
somehow unique to the left and a new
phenomenon that the right is immune to
is disingenuous at best and malicious at
worst the delusion and the hypocrisy
involved in this narrative are so
striking that it's difficult to even
know where to begin but let's start with
the idea that the biggest threat of
political violence today comes from the
left and look at that claim empirically
NPR recently spoke to experts who study
political violence and extremism in
order to fact-check the claim that
left-wing political violence is on the
rise
NPR determined that quote those who
track extremism say that while there are
a few far left groups that raise red
flags their numbers remain small the
groups being referred to largely fall
under the umbrella of antiphon or for
anti fascist the NPR article describes
an Tifa as quote loosely affiliated
groups of mostly young people
mainly on the west coast but spreading
around the country they dress in black
and wear masks when they confront
right-wing groups in the past few months
there have been clashes or
confrontations in Berkeley California
Portland Oregon and more recently on the
campus of Evergreen State College in
Olympia Washington
however these incidents have caused
conservative pundits like Tucker Carlson
to lose their minds and use the
ammunition to fan the flames of the
quote violent left narrative some of
these aunt offical ashes since Trump was
elected have resulted in broken property
rocks being thrown some minor injuries
nobody's been killed or seriously
injured during any of these clashes but
nonetheless these sorts of groups and
their tactics should be condemned and
monitored appropriately but Mark Pitts
cabbage a senior research fellow at the
anti-defamation league's Center on
extremism told NPR that the number of
far-left
an tyfa type extremists is tiny in
relation to the mainstream political
left quote the far left is very active
in the united states but it hasn't been
particularly violent for some time in
the past ten years when you look at
murders committed by domestic extremists
in the united states of all types
right-wing extremists are responsible
for about 74 percent of those murders
said pit cabbage to NPR this is the
crazy part despite the alarmism and
hysteria and sensationalized
fear-mongering about left-wing violence
the empirical truth of the matter is
that far-right extremism has been and
continues to be a far more significant
threat than far-left extremism even
during the age of Trump and the quote
resistance Ryan Morrow who I've
interviewed before a security analyst
with the Clarion project a right-wing
think-tank dedicated to quote
challenging radical Islam appeared on
Fox News recently and said quote anyone
that studies this kind of extremism or
terrorism knows that whichever political
party or political philosophy does not
control the White House
the extremism Rises on that side but
even if we take Mauro
at his word here right-wing extremism
still remains a significantly greater
threat according to experts and all
available statistics what exactly
qualifies as right-wing or left-wing
extremism what violent incidents are
counted in the sum total how the
severity of a threat is gauged these
sorts of variables vary between
organizations that study extremism but
by any metric right-wing extremism is
definitively and undeniably a far
greater threat so much so that it's more
or less on par with the threat posed by
jihadist Islamic extremism in this
country and you might be thinking David
no way that's an exaggeration fake news
maybe since 9/11 there have been more
deadly attacks committed by far-right
extremists in the United States than by
radical Islamists although more people
in total have been killed by Muslim
terrorists according to figures from an
exhaustive study by new America which
have been updated into 2017 there have
been at least twenty deadly attacks
motivated by far right-wing ideologies
in the u.s. since 9/11 resulting in the
deaths of 53 people comparatively there
have been 11 deadly attacks motivated by
radical Islam resulting in 95 deaths to
give you a sense of what sorts of
incidents new America is categorizing as
far right-wing attacks some examples are
the stabbing of two men in Oregon this
year by Jeremy Joseph Christian an
anti-muslim anti-semitic Nazi
sympathizing bigot who was harassing a
Muslim girl prior to the stabbing in
March 2017 Timothy Kaufman a black man
from New York City who was stabbed to
death with a sword by James Harris
Jackson a white man from Baltimore
Maryland who drove all the way to New
York City for the sole purpose of
killing a random innocent
african-american in 2015
three people were killed in a Colorado
Springs Planned Parenthood clinic in a
religiously motivated shooting and of
course nine black Americans were killed
in a church
in Charleston South Carolina by Dylan
roof a white supremacist
the list goes on and on and these are
just the deadly attacks that we're
talking about this doesn't include
assaults that didn't result in death nor
the dozens of far right-wing plots that
were foiled by law enforcement such as
when Robert dagger two former
congressional candidate from Tennessee
plotted to carry out an armed attack
against a Muslim majority town in rural
upstate New York a study from the
investigative fund and the National
Institute that came out this year found
that between 2008 and 2016 far-right
plots and attacks outnumbered Islamist
incidents by almost two to one the
Southern Poverty Law Center has compiled
a comprehensive list of right-wing
terrorism plots and attacks dating back
to 1995 and the sheer volume and
regularity of these incidents is
striking this is a well-established
issue in the United States there's
numerous available studies and reports
going back over the years that have all
come to similar conclusions these
studies include a 2015 study from the
triangle Center on terrorism and
homeland security and Duke University
titled law enforcement assessment of the
violent extremist threat
a 2009 Department of Homeland Security
Analysis titled right-wing extremism
current economic and political climate
fuelling resurgence and radicalization
and recruitment a 2012 Congressional
Research Service report titled the
domestic terrorist threat background and
issues for Congress a 2011 study done in
conjunction between the Department of
Homeland Security and the National
Consortium for the study of terrorism
and responses to terrorism and a 2002
FBI report to the Senate Intelligence
Committee right-wing extremist violence
is not just a problem in the United
States
just recently a far-right wing extremist
was arrested in France for plotting to
assassinate newly elected French
president McCrone in front of Donald
Trump and said after he was arrested
that he wanted to a
back quote Muslims Jews blacks and
homosexuals a right-wing extremist in
the UK plowed a van into a group of
people leaving a mosque in June a
right-wing extremist threw acid in the
face of two muslims in london
seriously maiming and disfiguring them
so yes anti-muslim anti black white
supremacist anti-semitic anti-government
anti-abortion ultra christian type
extremists represent a similar threat to
jihadist terrorism and that threat is
not going away anytime soon
experts are actually worried that Donald
Trump's victory has emboldened these
kinds of groups and we've seen early
evidence of upticks in those types of
hate crimes and attacks but Fox News and
other right-wing media outlets ignore
this threat instead focusing on the
so-called violent left in fact the
notion that far-right extremism
represents a major threat is scoffed at
on their network and it's not just Fox
News far-right wing extremism has been
shamefully a severely underreported
issue in the mainstream media in general
particularly when compared to the
sensationalized fear-mongering coverage
of Islamic terrorism another terrifying
facet of this is that the Trump
administration has recently frozen
funding slated by President Obama to go
to organizations that work to counter
right-wing extremism but now let's look
at the claim being made by many on the
right that the liberal media is
complicit in this supposed rise of
hatred and violence on the Left where we
truly get to the height of hypocrisy
Sean Hannity has said that liberals
particularly in the media have been
dehumanizing and objectifying
Republicans he also wrote in a column
for Fox News titled left-wing haters fan
the flames of rage violence that they
referring I guess to the left in general
may not be responsible for violence but
they have a responsibility to dial down
the hate before more people get hurt
do you believe
there is a link between the climate of
hatred for Muslims that Fox and other
conservative media quote did so much to
create and the many attacks and plots
against Muslim Americans perpetrated by
far-right radicals and Sean you want to
talk about dehumanizing and objectifying
people look at how you've personally
covered Muslims on your show the world's
gonna wake up to what I would say and
every radical Islamists like you will be
wiped off the face of the earth and look
at how you talk about refugees Isis and
al-qaeda not if they will infiltrate the
refugee community this president is
committed to nearly 250,000 coming to
America and just look at the kind of
hateful sometimes violent rhetoric
espoused by people on your side during
the eight years that Obama was president
he's a secret Muslim who wants to enact
Sharia law he's a traitor he hates
America and this wasn't only a problem
when Barack Obama was president it's
still a problem right now within days of
the shooting at the Republican baseball
practice
former Republican Congressman Joe Walsh
tweeted screw talks of bipartisanship
this country is at war with itself
choose your side and choose it now grab
your musket and get ready it's always
wise not to throw stones when you live
in a glass house and the audacity of
these conservative pundits to lecture
the left about toning down the rhetoric
is incredible and it's not just
conservative pundits in the media I mean
Donald Trump himself has openly and
brazenly encouraged violence against
demonstrators at his rallies I love the
old days you know what they used to do
to guys like that when they were in a
place like this they'd be carried out on
a stretcher folks
this rhetoric did materialize into real
violence a number of demonstrators
exercising their right to free speech
that conservatives love to champion were
assaulted and injured at Trump rallies
after Donald Trump literally called for
it
Trump campaign rallies often devolved
into cesspools of depraved hatred where
legitimately vile scornful violent
rhetoric was openly espoused by Trump
supporters political reported during the
campaign that refrains of hang the [ __ ]
and killed the [ __ ] were growing
increasingly common at Trump rallies
referring of course to Hillary Clinton a
trump supporter was photographed wearing
a t-shirt that said rope tree journalist
some assembly required Curt Schilling
the former major league baseball pitcher
turned conservative mouthpiece shared it
on Twitter and thought it was funny
where were all these conservative
pundits talking about toning down the
rhetoric then this widespread hateful
anti media rhetoric has also
materialized into real violence then
Republican candidate Greg John forté
body slammed the reporter and won a
congressional race the next day we're
not talking about dolls and plays here
we're talking about incidents of real
physical violence corresponding to
legitimately hateful rhetoric that's
widespread in conservative discourse and
remember when Trump said that Second
Amendment people might need to stop
Hillary Clinton from appointing liberal
justices to the Supreme Court if she
gets to pick her judges nothing you can
do folks
although the Second Amendment people
maybe there is I don't know or when he
had to fire his longtime Butler who
wrote on Facebook that Obama should be
shot as an enemy agent or when Trump
said we should kill the families of
terrorists and start torturing people
again or how about when Secret Service
agents had to interview a trump campaign
advisor who said Hillary Clinton should
be put in the firing line and shot for
treason or when his campaign advisor
Roger stone tweeted Clinton must be
brought to justice arrested tried and
executed for murder
I could legitimately go on for hours
citing countless examples of prominent
conservatives spewing legitimately
hateful and violent rhetoric all the
things Ted Nugent has said about Obama
alone could fill an entire show but just
as a quick reminder as I tell you this
right now if Barack Obama becomes the
president in November again I will
either be dead or in jail by this time
next year I will either be dead or in
jail do you really find any ambiguity in
that we need to ride into that
battlefield and chop their heads off
[Applause]
now that Donald Trump is in office
however Nugent is saying that quote we
have got to be civil to each other
that's all well and good but
conservatives can't pretend that people
from the right haven't been major
contributors to the culture of hatred
and violence they're currently railing
against now that their guy is in office
and we're not even really going to get
into how all of this is trivialized and
excused by conservatives who tell
liberals complaining about this type of
behavior that they're just triggered and
a bunch of special snowflakes who should
go back to their safe spaces what's the
truth although there may be some
legitimate reason to be concerned about
rhetoric on the left the possibility of
mentally unstable people who may take
the idea of the resistance too far both
hateful rhetoric and acts of political
violence are disproportionately a
problem on the right not the left this
is yet another example of the major
projection that is common to right-wing
politics in the United States if
conservatives want to have a legitimate
discussion about the political climate
civility and rhetoric they really have
to take a look in the mirror first the
david pakman show at david pakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
so last week we occur akane harvey in
texas now we have a category 5 hurricane
hurricane
Irma heading towards the United States
expected to make landfall for the first
time likely will hit the US over the
weekend although being a few days out
still the model of its exact path is not
as accurate as it will be in another 24
to 48 hours in the meantime Puerto Rico
will be hit as well as the island of
hven gia as early as tomorrow and Irma
is one of these it's called a Cape Verde
hurricane meaning that it formed in the
very far eastern part of the Atlantic
Ocean
near the Cape Verde Islands and then
came across the Atlantic and those
storms often become some of the largest
some of the most intense hurricanes
Hurricane Hugo Floyd Ivan were all Cape
Verde storms and whenever there's a
hurricane like I told you last week the
anti-science right says oh we can't talk
about climate change now it's it's it's
bad you can't play politics with a
natural disaster don't do it it's bad
it's mean it's deceptive and of course
as I said last week the reality is any
opportunity to talk about climate change
is a good one and there is a
relationship between extreme weather and
climate change individual hot days or a
single snowstorm these are weather
events but the longer term changes in
frequency of those weather events and
their severity we could be talking about
rainfall snow record heat record cold
severe storms that is part of climate
change now the relationship is not super
simple okay it's it's not totally
straightforward where you say well
climate change causes X when it comes to
weather events some ways in which these
elements are linked can include world
temperatures rising on average and
warmer temperatures we know serve to
fuel more intense tropical storms and
hurricanes that might mean more storms
it could mean more intense storms it
could mean that would be tropical storms
instead develop into more severe
hurricanes because of warmer ocean water
for example it's never simple
and the anti-science right
really really wants simple in other
words they want either climate change
causes hurricanes or climate change
doesn't cause hurricanes and the reality
is always something more like well in
areas predisposed to tropical storms
climate change can have a cyclically
strengthening impact on storms when I
hear that I say oh well number one we
should be funding more research into the
relationship between climate change and
individual weather events and number two
we should immediately come up with a
plan to mitigate the effects of our
activities on earth on the other hand
you've got the anti science right who
hears well it's a complex relationship
between climate and weather they say oh
well then we shouldn't do anything
because it's not at all clear that human
activities impact climate at all and
that could not be more of a sort of
ostrich bury your head in the sand
perspective on this I think there's a
lot of lessons that we can learn from
these extreme weather events so you take
hurricane Harvey that hit Houston I mean
it just reinforces the idea that we need
stronger zoning laws and the areas like
that we need you know to preserve our
wetlands and prairies so the water has
somewhere to drain out to and you know
maybe that may mean some short-term
economic losses oh yeah in the future it
helps us out a great deal and we also
have to support FEMA and disaster relief
effort it's just like what you know I
when I talked to climate science deniers
and I try not to do it super often you
really don't get many people who just
straight up say I'll be dead so I don't
care very few people actually say that
they do seem to say hey you know I don't
want to leave the planet in a situation
that's gonna be worse for my children
grandchildren great-grandchildren
whatever they don't seem totally
disconnected in a sort of sociopathic
way from the future but they just seem
to deny the ability of humans to
actually impact the climate they cast
doubt on we can't really know that you
know the earth has been around for so
long and we've only had temperature
measurements for the last 200 years or
whatever they parrot out some debunked
tired talking point and and yet it still
doesn't matter if you bash them over the
head with facts it's not going to change
their mind so it's a really difficult
conversation to have I feel like they're
just telling themselves that because
then they can
move themselves from any responsibility
they don't have to change their
lifestyle or I think some crisis
repercussions and you know maybe they do
care about how their kids and grandkids
are going to be in the future but maybe
they also think they can solve the
problem because we'll have improved
technology then that's another one which
is the idea that hey I don't deny that
we're having an impact I just believe
that our technology will always be one
step ahead of that impending disaster
and I say to them you know how many
people already died in China due to air
pollution do you have any idea it's not
some far-off thing it's happening now it
is happening right now we have a
voicemail number it's to 192 david p a
lot of people pat angry that i do not
watch and have never watched a full
episode of game of thrones one person
happy about it it's the Eggman dave
there are a lot of things about you that
i totally love the thing i love the most
is that you've never seen a game of
thrones program so i haven't either
you're good man okay that was it yeah i
got a ton of email from people saying
david you need to understand that
there's so many lessons to be learned
from Game of Thrones politically
socially culturally etc and my response
continues to be I don't have HBO yeah I
I feel like the Eggman respects you
because you know what you're talking
about when it comes to politics and
economics and and all these different
topics but really this whole time he
respected you more for what you didn't
know which is that you haven't even seen
Game of Thrones that's right and I don't
even know like I heard something about
Ed Sheeran like was Ed Sheeran in an
episode or is there a character that
looks like Ed Sheeran Lee have no idea I
don't know what's going on with Game of
Thrones would you be surprised that the
Eggman calls back in in like a month's
time and says you have to watch Game of
Thrones because he got sucked in yeah I
would not be nothing the Eggman would
potentially do would surprise me okay
we've got another non-scientist
put in place of a science agency this
time it's NASA I will talk about some
small changes that everybody can do to
reduce waste in their daily life but
what I really want to get at is whether
these changes are so small as to be
insignificant and we will also talk
about Elon Musk's very dire predictions
about World War three and it has
according to him
nothing to do with Kim jong-un or North
Korea or anything of the sort it has to
do with something very very different
and we'll talk about that on the bonus
show how do you get access to the bonus
show there are now soon to be multiple
ways number one old faithful
membership you sign up at david
pakman.com slash membership you can get
$1 trial membership at david pakman.com
slash dollar with peace and love try it
out you get the bonus show soon I would
predict within 7 to 10 days
the bonus show will also be a patreon
benefit at the $5 patron level
patreon.com slash david pakman show so
anyway
more on that later this week early next
week we'll talk to you on the bonus show
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
you